[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
classroom
yo check this out
do
[Music]
this is
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
don't check this out
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
on
pretty cheap
okay
uh
okay
huh
uh
foreign
[Music]
hi i'm leon chen product marketing
manager at razer and i'm travis director
of marketing for the razer systems
business unit thanks for joining us at
razorstore live cs edition we're excited
to share with you all the new things we
have in store with the pandemic going on
the team at razer has continued to
develop and bring you some cool features
i'm sure many of you have been wanting
to see just last year we released the
razer blade 14 the first ever razer
blade built on an amd processor and it
was no coincidence that our blade 14 was
the most powerful and the thinnest
14-inch gaming laptop in the world we
also launched the razer book quartz the
latest intel evo certified laptop with
features like instant on all day battery
life for professionals who want a
portable workstation that's as efficient
as it is eye-catching and today we're
bringing new iterations of all your
favorite razer blade gaming laptops our
latest 2020 editions promise even faster
performance as well as a whole new suite
of improved features let's talk intel
this might be my all-time favorite
iteration of the blade 15 and 17. first
off lots of changes on the internals we
have the new 12th gen 14 core intel
processor and the latest nvidia geforce
rtx 30 ti series graphics and don't
forget that with the new razer systems
on the intel platform you now have ddr5
and those incredibly fast displays from
360hz full hd 240 hertz qhd and a brand
new 4k 144 hertz display option the new
blades cater to a variety of users
ranging from gamers or even content
creators let's see what our partners
have to say about the new performance
improvements on the new blade 15. thank
you razer for having us at razorstore
live ces edition
as you just saw here at ces we launched
the rest of the 12th generation family
following the highly successful launch
of the core i9 12900k the world's best
gaming processor with the best
overclocking experience made for the
gamer and creator in mind
today i'm happy to tell you about our
12th generation h-series product and our
partnership with razer to bring even
more performance to their blade line of
laptops
to describe our 12th generation h series
launch in one word
wow
it's our fastest mobile processor ever
i really hope you're all as excited as i
am to put it to the test with razer's
amazing lineup intel's new performance
core micro architecture is the highest
performing cpu core we've ever built i'm
excited to say that razer's taking full
advantage of this performance by pairing
their blade line of laptops with our i7
12800h and i9 12900h cpus it's really
exciting to see what they can do in such
a small and compact design
so really what are our performance cores
in our efficiency cores well the
performance or p cores are optimized for
single and lightly threaded performance
which enhances gaming and productivity
workloads
our new efficient core micro
architecture is really designed for
throughput efficiency which enables
scalable multi-threaded performance for
modern multitasking
with 10 to 20 percent speed up on single
threaded workloads from ipc gains of the
p core 30 to 40 percent speed up in
multi-threaded workloads from the p
cores working in junction with the
e-cores this sets a new bar for mobile
performance
the main intent of this hybrid
architecture is really all about
adaptability for real-world usages and
these cores help enable that of course
our 12th generation 8 series support all
major memory technologies razer in fact
is using our 4 800 megahertz ddr5 for
the best cpu bandwidth to memory that is
50 faster clock speeds than before
on i o the 12th generation series
supports 16 lanes of pcie gen 4 by 8 for
discrete graphics and up to 2 by 4s for
dual ssd configs
connectivity is also world class in case
you're wondering about that because all
of the new 12th generation h series
razer blade 15 inch 8 inch and 17 inch
systems will have best in class killer
ax 1690 wi-fi
this has that double connect technology
and this killer software stack and
includes double shot and the priority
engine
when you pair these significant gains in
performance with the razer gear and you
get one incredible gaming or creator
experience and don't forget our 12th
generation h series offers that is not
just for gamers it's perfect for
creators as well
creators need that performance that low
latency and those high frame rates just
like our gaming community
we really work closely with developers
to optimize both the performance and
realism on the 12th generation core
systems through windows quality of
service apis asynchronous tasks like ai
acceleration character animation
destruction physics and background tasks
like audio are all shifted towards those
efficiency cores while the main
rendering threads and game threads are
ensured the highest quality of service
on those performance cores and as seen
as our hit in our hitman 3 testing this
optimization increased performance on
the 12th generation cores by up to 8
percent
razer's really been an incredible
partner with us for many many years now
integrating several generations of our
cpus into their product line and i'm
pleased that our 12th generation will be
no exception
we're really excited to work with razer
again to incorporate our newest
technologies into their products to
deliver the best experiences to their
community
in addition to our technical partnership
we've really also enjoyed collaborating
with razer on many engaging activations
for our joint gaming community across
the globe including other razer story
live events game intel gamer days
sweepstakes and bundles and many many
more we really look forward to
delivering more outstanding technical
and community experiences in the years
to come
razor team thanks for having me on your
stream today thanks for inviting us to
your razor store live ces edition we are
excited to partner with you again for
the latest generation of blade laptops
and everyone knows razer blade laptops
are amazing devices they're sleek super
powerful and packed with the latest tech
for whatever you're doing of course
being from nvidia my favorite part of
these laptops is the new geforce rtx
gpus we just announced the geforce rtx
3080 ti and 30 70 time the 3080 ti
laptop gpu is a beast it's faster than a
titan rtx desktop gpu that is insane
titan rtx on a desktop it's actually
faster than that and it packs 16
gigabytes of the fastest ever g6 memory
plenty for anything you throw at it you
can game at 120 plus fps at 1440p it's
also amazing for content creation you
can edit 8k60 video or render massive 3d
scenes the new rtx 3070 ti is also a
killer laptop gpu it delivers up to 70
percent more performance compared to a
2070 super that's the same class of gpu
in our previous generation it's 70
faster than that but regardless of the
rtx gpu you choose razer's range of 14
inch to 17 inch designs they're super
fast 360hz displays or their stunning 4k
resolution displays the future of laptop
gaming and creating is bright as you
know these new gpus are built on our
award-winning ampere architecture you've
all heard about it it enables features
like ray tracing for the most realistic
and immersive graphics dlss which uses
ai to boost frame rates without
compromising image quality and of course
nvidia reflex for low latency
competitive gaming
and our gpus boost more than just gaming
and creating performance they also
supercharge stem applications enabling
students to work faster and complete
coursework sooner one student and parent
wouldn't like that but here at nvidia we
don't only focus on the gpu we think
about the entire system the entire
laptop we want thin quiet laptops with
high performance and great battery life
to achieve all this we partnered closely
with razer to integrate a suite of
laptop technologies that we call max-q
now we introduced max q back in 2017 and
there has been a ton of progress over
the years this version of maxq is
precisely tuned for this new generation
of laptops cpu efficiency is improved
yes that's right we're now on to
improving cpu efficiency in addition to
gpu efficiency
battery life is longer while gaming and
creating on the go is much faster
razer's new line of laptops powered by
geforce rtx delivers amazing features
and technologies for gamers creators and
students
in fact i've got one sitting here it's
been staring at me the whole time i'm
gonna take this home with me sorry razer
you're gonna have a tough time getting
this back
thanks again for your partnership and
have an excellent event
thank you intel at nvidia for running us
through your latest cpu and gpu
technology that drives even more
performance to our displays besides the
blazing fast displays we have a very
very cool vapor chamber to make sure
everything is running smoothly under the
hood instead of a traditionally
air-cooled laptop a vapor timber system
is more effective as it contains liquid
that transfers into gas and drives that
heat out of the system thanks to this
feature we can utilize every inch of the
chassis to maximize thermal threshold
and squeeze every ounce of fps out of
the laptop but what's more the new blade
also boasts several modifications to
enhance its thermal performance from the
underside alone you can see that we've
split the rubber feet and added
additional air vents this allows cool
air to get into the system compared to
our original vapor chamber we've
increased the amount of liquid as well
as the number of fins and fans in the
cooling system and we also leverage
nanoparticle thermal blockers and server
grade components all of these parts work
together to allow us to push the
performance further and aside from this
we also made a lot of changes to the
keyboard yeah for the blade 15 and the
blade 17 we've increased the size of the
keyboard pool this is the grooved area
where the keyboard rests inside
and we've also made the keys even larger
for overall better typing experience in
addition we've tuned the switch click
force to make them even snappier and
more responsive but perhaps one of my
personal favorite design changes is the
new speaker grills are now laser cnc cut
for a much more elegant design yeah
that's something i'm definitely excited
about and i'm sure many others who are
interested in razer blades are as well
for the 17 inch blade it's got so many
features we just covered and also some
additional ones such as a larger 84 watt
hour battery for longer battery life and
more importantly eight and i mean eight
thx certified speakers with more
speakers the laptop is able to deliver a
fuller sound filled with more
characteristics for a truly cinematic
audio experience we've even improved on
the speaker placement to where these
speakers are both upward and downward
firing now that we've covered both the
15 and 17 inch what other features will
we see in the blade 14. well the blade
14 is getting a lot of changes as well
first coming new to the blade 14 is an
updated amd cpu it now features the
newly announced amd ryzen 9 6900 hx
class processor this provides the blade
14 with an incredible amount of
performance and 8 cores 20 megs of cash
and up to 4.6 gigahertz of max boost
when it launched last year the blade 14
was the first 14 inch gaming laptop with
the geforce rtx 3070 and 3080 graphics
let's come what's in store for them this
year for 2022 we'll be updating the new
blade 14 with the new nvidia geforce rtx
ti graphics and with up to 16 gigs of
vram in the new 3080 ti model coupled
with an integrated mux chip we're really
unleashing the performance this time
around as the laptop display has full
access to the gpu this allows us to push
up to 15 higher performance when in the
gpu only mode that's awesome i know
that's something we've been asked about
a lot i know aside from those updates
we're also doubling down on camera
resolution that's correct with video
calling becoming the new norm we're
doubling it to 1080p on the web camera
and since the laptop is going to see a
ton of use the anti-fingerprint
resistant coating will also be now
available in the blade 14 so you don't
have to worry about extra smudges and
always trying to clean it off well i
know i'm excited about the new blade
laptops for those of you watching tell
us what you're excited about and even
what you'd like to see in the next razer
blade and you can learn even more about
the new laptops and pre-order select
models exclusively right now on
razer.com thank you for watching us at
razer store live cs edition and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
let's go
alright
this
uh
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey guys i'm carl conrad a tech content
creator and i'm going to show you the
brand new razer by fossil gen 6 smart
watch so this is a limited edition smart
watch and as you can see it's built
around a 1.28 inch ammo led display that
features three unique razer watch faces
like razer chroma you can track all of
your fitness related stats like steps
heart rate and even spo2 and for juicing
up you get around 80 with just a 30
minute charge like i mentioned it's a
limited edition model only
1337 models coming out that's one three
three seven that's leet january 10th you
don't want to miss it
make sure you pick one up
okay
uh
okay
yes
okay
uh
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to the consumer
electronics expo for 2022 we're here at
the razor booth and i'm joined with my
good friend wavepunk and we're going to
be taking a quick tour of everything
that razer is going to be showing off
and taking us through all of that will
be my other buddy will powers will
what do you have in store for us today
we have so much to show today at uh ces
for you rachel and caleb so uh let's go
check it out
these these chairs are wonderful i know
i'm sad to leave them behind you come
back
there's so much chroma here already i'm
sorry i'm getting hung up on just the
place where we started well i think
we're gonna head over here first
and tell me about this room because i'm
seeing lots of colors lots of different
designs
there's a christmas tree christmas is
over why is the christmas tree still up
because we have so much to show
this is the smart home setup wave
and what we're showing off today at ces
and smart home is really razer bringing
chroma from the desktop into the smart
home everyone has so many different
smart home products whether it's
yeelight whether it's twinkly or nano
leaf that is nano leaf right behind us
good eye
but there is no unified way to control
them all within chroma until today so
razer's launching the chroma smart home
app to have a unified solution on your
smartphone to control everything in your
smart home one device all the all the
things i love it because there's so many
different brands that do so many
different cool things love the twinkly
love the nano leaf now it's all sticky
on top of the tree and one's good at the
top of this oh you've got to have snakey
everywhere a little bit of an angel
okay so this room i no razor green is
what i think of when i think of razer
products everything in here is quartz i
mean this is
different room different length this is
crazy i want to see the quartz stuff oh
i didn't realize actually how many
different quartz products there were but
i think that's one of the cool things
about the mercury the quartz the razer
green that you do is you can get an
entire setup all in one color it looks
so clean
that's what we want to do we wanted to
show off the options of creating the
ultimate setup
with whatever color you want we have all
these products so you can pick the spec
pick the tech that you want but now you
can also pick the color and the look
because we release things in all these
different color ways whether it's in
quartz whether it's in mercury or the
traditional black and razer green that
you talked about gotcha can't believe
you even have the floor mats even the
floor mats yeah i mean esports doesn't
mean you can't be a fan of courts too
esports esports has done anything gamers
love bright colors so this room is
perfect i'm excited to see
more here let's there's so many bright
colors in this booth this is my favorite
it's ces we gotta have the bright shiny
things for you let's go razer knows what
they're doing you can spot the razor
booth across the floor and
i know if you don't find it by accident
you're finding it intentionally because
you've had a number of razor blade
announcements already hit the news yeah
exactly so uh the blade announcements
came uh directly with our partners so we
have partners at amd intel and nvidia
and we're so excited that our early 2022
line of razer blades in 14 15 and 17
inch chassis have the brand new
generations of amd and intel cpus as
well as the new generations of nvidia
gpus so these guys come with nvidia 37
or 3080 ti's in them which is amazing
top of the line products wow so i think
we've got more diesel details about that
later as well i'm interested in this
part we have the the wearable gear from
razer we have glasses we have a mat with
the zephyr
and this is the zephyr pro pronoun pro
exactly okay so i have a zephyr i'm a
big fan of it how did you even upgrade
that product so one of the things that
we noticed with zephyr is because of the
seal around your nose and mouth some uh
some of the fans of it wanted to be a
little less muffled because it has such
a perfect seal around just give me a
little bit of the uh give me the man
please yeah so i've got to get to that
in a second you're going to jump ahead
of me but uh so one of the feature sets
that we put into pro was voice
amplification so there's actually two
speaker grills in the zephyr pro as well
as a microphone to really amplify your
voice
60 decibels in a one meter radius
and excited to confirm that we also have
voice modifications are you serious so
you can do your vein boards i was just
joking you put them but you already you
already had the voice naturally but now
people be able to hear you too so i just
open up the app and i can change what
what
is going on here actually actually i see
it on your wrist as well we have smart
watches now yeah so we have a
partnership another partnership we have
with fossil you notice that uh with
razer we have partnership across a ton
of lifestyle and fashion brands we have
partnership with vape previously and now
we're expanding our wearables as well as
our fashion and lifestyle lines with a
partnership with fossil so you can see
on my wrist here
this is actually the fossil gen 6 smart
watch this is the first limited edition
they have ever done on this brand new
gen 6 smart watch from uh from fossil so
what's the fossil stuff and what's the
razer stuff
really what razer brought to the table
is this is razer software with fossil
hardware
so there are three custom razer
faceplates you saw chroma uh that's
being displayed here uh there's another
one that is digital another one that is
analog as well as a custom charging and
boot up screen okay as and then you get
two different this is your razor green
and black yeah
let everybody know exactly exactly so
normally it comes with a leather uh
leather wristband but the razer limited
edition one comes with those uh razer
green and razer black ones and only 1 37
of them going up for sale of course of
course of course
we see you um this this this is the look
i'm used to
with with a razor setup this is the
going in chief the ultimate pc setup
i've been told
exactly so we wanted to showcase here
what you could do if you had everything
razer so we have three raptor uh 27-inch
displays we have our kio pro webcam we
have our siren v2 pro uh
microphone or dynamic microphone uh
everything razer to get the ultimate pc
set up
and just showcase what's possible here
we're going to be streaming from the
booth
throughout ces and using our setup to
actually broadcast ces out to the world
now i do think you guys put a bunch of
beautiful hardware in here but razer
community i know you're looking at this
and you're thinking you can really deck
this desk out and i look forward to
seeing exactly how you use all these
products throughout the year at our
other razer store lives you guys could
have put a bit more lights on this thing
come on well we did if you look over
here to the right but show me where the
one thing that we actually are
showcasing for the first time here at
ces is a build of our pc components that
we announce at razor con so you'll see
our all-in-one liquid cooler our kunai
fans our pwm fam controller as well as
the uh as the power supply all in there
all lit up with chroma and controlled uh
directly through synapse that is a
good-looking case
well let's i i there was this huge thing
we walked past there's so much pretty
stuff here okay we have the controllers
but look
look look at it look at the bright
colors look at all the prettiness look i
play so much forza horizon's fight that
controller is incredible right there and
i this this stuff is great though i'm
really curious though will about what's
behind us
this this incredible you got it yes
there's a lot of stuff no
no we can't talk about the headsets
there's things to talk about here
because before we move on i want to talk
about we got the razer uh these are
wolverines wolverine v2 chroma's
beautiful but tell me a little bit more
about what i'm seeing here because this
looks like it's straight from the xbox
factory these controllers you're way
brighter than you think you are on that
one
so one thing that we have to talk about
is we have direct integration into
xbox's supply chain because of our great
relationship we've had with them for so
many years with our laptops and windows
and microsoft in general so we are the
only only third party partner that has
the exact same paints the exact same
resonance in the exact same plastics for
seven different xbox controllers
including their top five best-selling
models so you see
the aqua shift controller here and the
direct color matching of our uh
universal fast charging stand and those
pieces are cool the 20th anniversary
stand the forts of horizons 5-1 as well
as some limited edition boba fett and
mandalorian ones that we that we do
ourselves
call me a millennial but i love that you
can see the guts in the controller this
is like the old controller vibe i'm
really into that one there playstation
looks really nice too exactly so what
we're showing off here is everything
console we have all of our best tech our
50 millimeter triforce drivers our
universal uh charging stands for both
dual shock as well as the xbox
controllers and our brand new cairo
models for xbox and playstation and also
we have more of that over here
we do see i'm seeing like a perfect
lineup of razer headsets will look like
actual xbox controllers yeah so
everything we showed in the case this is
kind of it in its native environment
okay if you will this is like kind of a
zoo setup this is the dream setup
the fantasy i don't live in new zealand
so these are the top five best-selling
xbox color controllers that we talked
about and just showing off the perfect
console room
it's gorgeous okay it's like if this is
the zoo then my enclosure is enriched
now can we talk about the thing in the
middle because this is what i want to
talk this this is crazy
what is this
this is
look at this look at it what is this
you don't know this is this is this is
project
sofia look at it all here this is it's a
what i've been told is this is a desk
that like this is the the next
generation of gaming desk first off this
is part of the desktop this is the unit
the speaker's everything it's this isn't
just a tv they put above the desk this
is this and this is the computer though
right right okay so everything is one
thing this is the world's first i'll
channel
uh modular gaming desktop uh so what
that means is everything here is an
individual modular modular component
that you put in to customize the gpu the
cpu all the components this is smooth
wow this is where it underneath it's all
wireless it's all inductive charging
so that this can be fully customized to
whatever you want to use your
workstation for and like you said wave
this is a 65 inch display that's built
in
to this entire setup oh my goodness so
and to my team there will be more
components necessarily than slots so you
customize the desk to whatever your
specific needs are so many more exactly
i mean this is a concept product so it's
this isn't something that we're
releasing to the public for sale but
we're showing off what the future can
look like because it's ces yeah yeah
yeah we got to talk about the future i'm
saying
this is a coffee warmer rachel this is
the future this is this is i'm going to
buy cold brew i'm going to put it on the
coffee warm we're going to heat it up
into hot coffee but
the the options are endless because i
think like you said this is a this is a
gamer setup it's a pretty regular gamer
they're they're doing some movie
watching they got their spell slots over
there yeah they've got the volume
controls but if i were a dj if i were a
video editor oh yeah
video editor having like buttons that i
can just like just put dedicated on a
desk instead of having to go and find
and click it in a menu so nice if you're
a graphic designer you can choose change
one of these gui interfaces into a
stylus and draw directly on the frame
that you're working on on the screen the
whole thing is a color wheel put twitch
chat on the screen here instead of
having like find like an extra space in
the monitor next to some other thing
that yeah i know this is great okay so
i'm still looking at the desk i mean
he's got the of course it's got a chroma
up there
it's incredible were you gonna ask if it
had chrome no i was just geeking out a
little bit let's talk about the chair
though because this is the biggest
platform i feel like i've ever seen on a
gaming chair i've been told this is the
enki pro hypersense let's break that
down yes yes because you said three
really important words there you said
anki which is our second family of
gaming chairs obviously we have the
iskar which is our first line and then
anki which is about all-day comfort and
then pro it's a top-line model uh and
then hypersense you guys have to be
familiar that means haptics built-ins
okay i did notice that you pointed out
that giant bass it says d-box on it it
does okay they're a pretty famous brand
so those are all the same guys that
you'll know from uh the high-end theater
and uh immersive theme park experiences
of the really really uh haptic base
chairs of sound and everything built
into them we partnered with them for the
technology behind this concept product
so so not so hyper sense is obviously
haptic feedback but correct the box also
does with actual motion actual movement
it's not just the the chair exactly it's
vibrating it's it's not your rumble
packs that you think of from the 90s
it's really smart and intelligent
haptics that are based on direct input
from what's happening in the game and in
the entertainment around you and
incorporating that into this so at the
base what you see is a giant haptics
engine but there's also haptics
incorporated throughout the back and the
base of the chair over 46 000 different
haptic variations this chair is capable
of i mean when i think of haptics one of
the things i always think of is the
forza series and how well they approach
the actual real-life experience of
driving
my napping chair and my racing chair it
looks comfortable i mean somewhere in
between like full racing sim which is
its own dedicated thing versus here
combine this setup this desk with this
chair you you you're close to having a
racing system
that's your normal gaming space exactly
so immersiveness is all about one the
technology but also about the content so
the great thing about this and because
of our uh our partnership with d-box we
have over
2200 different titles that this chair is
already compatible with whether it's
forza horizons 5 like you already talked
about or other racing games like f1 from
codemasters and ea or even some action
games like assassin's creed valhalla for
ubisoft well i'm thinking of forza
immediately because i'm thinking of how
well they render the driving experience
where you can feel the grit of the road
depending on what kind of asphalt you're
driving on so have they brought those
experiences they put into their thrust
master they put into their sims that's
actually in the chair like what am i
gonna feel when i sit down on this and
[ __ ] and drive well exactly what you
talked about whether it's the asphalt
and then you won't feel much because
it's smooth okay or the gravel or if
you're like me and you just crash into
trees you'll feel all of that maybe
maybe not that one
i also noticed
with chroma well this thing is powered
caleb might as well if we're bringing
power to the chair with the haptics
we're going to slap some chrome in it
too man what a cool thing to debut at
ces this is awesome i love it i love
that it works with games too and i don't
want to let this go without mentioning
that it also works with passive viewing
experiences it's got ties in with a lot
of shows and movies exactly so whether
it's netflix and the latest witcher
title that just came out or disney plus
in the latest book of bubba fett all of
those disney plus and netflix high-end
titles are already directly integrated
so you can enjoy passive entertainment
like you talked about in this high-end
entertainment chair it's really a
theater experience for you at home can
you imagine on this massive screen
this tricked out the way you need it and
then right in your
2022 right
this is this is incredible man i can't
wait to hopefully someday get my hands
on the products i just understand these
are just concepts right now but maybe in
the future i will thanks so much for
giving us a tour of the booth thank you
wave thank you rachel as always guys
great talking to you thanks for the tour
back to us at the store
[Music]
me
foreign
let's go
um okay
okay
good
thank you
uh
oh
okay
uh
yes
uh
three
quick
uh
right
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
okay
if
yes
good
thank you
yes
what
okay
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
good
um
okay
um
so
[Music]
[Music]
i